depuis sa création en 1970 la vocation
ultime du journal charlie hebdo est
clair faire rire et dérangé en
bousculant les lignes ligne de conduite
qui divisent les français mais pas
seulement
les abdos encore à torun charlie hebdo
tollens catena avec les tickets
protestent car cette fois ci le journal
satirique semble avoir réussi sa mission
à l'international avec sa dernière une
concernant meghan markle et la reine
elizabeth ii
suite à l'interview qu'on donnait harry
et mégane à oprah winfrey la semaine
dernière je ne voulais plus me taire
dans l'émoi
je ne voulais plus être en raison des
caricatures assez peu avantageuse de
mégane mais surtout de la reine qui a
beaucoup agacé le peuple britannique
surtout que ce dessin détourne image
très fort des policiers qui aux états
unis ont tué georges floyd en
l'empêchant de respirer un crime de lèse
majesté qui a beaucoup de mal à passer
outre manche alors affaire mégane et
harry comprenez vous la colère des
anglais après la une de charlie hebdo
alors oui vous la comprenez ah ouais moi
jusqu'au ça insupportable comme
référence à geof lloyd les une de
charlie pardon mais j'ai jamais été
charlie
j'ai toujours détesté ce qu'ils vivent
et ce qu'ils faisaient comme une parce
que je les trouve trop trop provocatrice
mais comment autant on est tous charlie
non je suis pas charlie hebdo
j'ai été très solidaire déjà sur charlie
évidemment mais mais non je peux pas
dire parce qu'ils ont eu ses drames que
je suis pour les une de charlie wi
beaucoup trop loin
la just royce est beaucoup trop récent
et puis ça va quoi on met on en est loin
de là la vieille qui écrase béganne fin
je trouve ça gerber concernés douce un
journal satirique un journal
d'actualités en plus il inventorie
allaoui à des tensions entre megan et
buckingham où il ya des accusations de
racisme comment ils sont pleinement dans
leur rôle en plus pour ce que nie megan
ni buckingham sont à une de presse près
justement ils ont l'habitude de se faire
défoncer tout le temps dans la presse ou
compris dans la presse britannique
donc je pense que franchement ça ça pas
les choquer nos wii gilles j'ai hurlé de
rire
très franchement pour moi c'est un
critère y avait plein de une de charlie
hebdo qui ne m'avait pas plu là je
continue à rire je prouve qu'elle est
très bien faite elle est drôle tête
pascal et elle te concerne pas mais non
mais ça te ferait moins les anglais sont
trop susceptible avec saïfi qui
relâchent un peu les anglais quand même
heureux d'étendre et de styles ce soit
ils s'en sont remis les anglais il faut
arrêter ils sont pas choqués c'est juste
que c'est les français qui parlent de ça
et aujourd'hui dans le contexte actuel
être excité tout ça ça laisse aller sa
hystérise tous nos tests au sol soit
choqué oui en fait moi j'apprends les
choquée je suis char lire je peux pas
dire je suis pas chaoui mais en fait
c'est à dire que c'est pas du tout la
même notion en fait du vivre ensemble et
du rapport entre les différentes
techniques en angleterre donc il faut
aussi prendre ça en compte et à mon sens
c'est un petit peu tôt par rapport à
georges de floyd
voilà c'est mal mais c'est que mon point
de vue je trouve que c'est un petit peu
délicat
ouais enfin alors j'ai utilisé les shows
qui est aussi ma chérie comme si j'étais
anglais mais je serais choqué mais
attention le couple le chic anglais le
coup pilar épargné justement la règle
très comme la comme l'instigatrice de ça
c'est pas bien et en plus les anglais
doute de la véracité de megan d'auckland
où tu lui dis c'est une menteuse donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a eue le port est
ce que les français prennent sa cause et
comprennent pas alors on a oublié un
gars dont l'émission qui est là je
l'avais complètement oublié c'est
bernard montiel bernard merci mais non
merci donc à moi c'est vrai que si je
n'avais pas vu tien tu étais là je sais
je dis rien derrière koh lanta je m'en
fous ah ben là je vais vous dire tu as
raison mais tu as raison je regardais
les césars dont car c'est toi viens de
regarder
alors oui là moi j'ai trouvé évidemment
je comprends que ça choque moi je trouve
ça très bien qu'il la regardait césar
c'est pour ça que tu es encore pas mis
longtemps
oui dans kampala les césars c'était
super à strass alors mon nom sera le
gros débris mais je trouve que ce qui
est choquant peut-être c'est les poils
qui s'enfuit sur les os des pattes de la
dame de la reine alors délaissé quelques
mois tu compte démarrer dès missions que
j'ai à 19h31 but monnet paquet alors non
je te comprends que les anglais soient
choqués mais moi ça m'amuse beaucoup
cette couverture c'est peut-être un peu
trop tôt pour geof c'est choquant bien
sûr d'autant plus qu'on a bien dit que
c'était pas la reine qui est heureux que
réunira genre de réflexion insupportable
intolérable bien sûr donc c'est un peu
beaucoup mais c'est l'humour du charlie
hebdo il ya eu pire mais la référence à
georges tron est trop trop présente
encore pour moi je resterai on peut
aller encore beaucoup plus loin la dèche
pas ce que tu en penses mandant le cfa
n'apparaissent qu'en fait on peut dire
aussi que finalement charlie hebdo prend
fait et cause pour buckingham palace
mais on va dire qu'on fait ils disent
que megan quelque part c'est la pauvre
petite fille victime yves et qui dit
qu'elle n'est que et voilà que c'était
racine cubique icade c'était horrible et
finalement il ya un truc qui est
peut-être aussi de sa part mais place et
voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
tient sur sa wii 54 pour son nom 46 % et
100 %
keith en maths légal